what some fool podcast with Rodrigo
Torres Felipe Esparza hosting always
healthy
well do your co-hosting yeah man you
know me were so fool killing plane can
we start
what's up also man with your getting a
new logo man for the podcast have you
guys been getting submissions hell no
and taking that one right we're gonna
have a contest but see man a lot of
people man they just don't know how to
submit why we had a contest for my one
hour special man it may give us a who
the content we were looking for somebody
to do the arm the album cover or the
logo they're gonna pull it out to
promote it I post the house attention to
one hour special poster so a lot of you
who are submitting their best friends
and and a lot of people who would say
man if you know if you go to photoshop
and you can do posters you could do
Flyers cool man
I have a web page you know someone's get
a hold of you touch it [ __ ] okay now
email me go here with my number man
underground so I'm gonna put in your
house no panic room in a bunker
somewhere Exhibit B how are you living
up off the grid how we're gonna find you
man you gonna find them around the
corner four frets taller a lot of people
wanna do father
the poster ballad to his flyers bro I'm
done with flyers how to do a flyer now
anybody could do a fire but they asked
you to submit it they ask you for the
address so you could yeah right now that
reminds me we're numb gave her a glance
of the night where I'm working with Luke
Taurus oh [ __ ] the good old Luke torrid
and being Gabriel edge now we're gonna
kill it row and make them full work [ __ ]
this guy the secretary said that and it
didn't happen so he'll we do both two to
ten thirty minutes and that want to do
forty five so we're each other killer
but I stomping yelling on Spanish words
and we killed it this foot does 30 foot
to an hour those
thirty all right of good comedy you know
good comedy
Luke Torres and then the curtain drops
of full-on heavy metal band behind him
bro oh and you never doing it when he
first started pulling that [ __ ] on your
musicians do like the first time we did
it and he impersonated 10 different
singer bro actual when that food that
food put on a wig and put it to the side
with a beanie and put on this ugly-ass
sweater and you put a head down bro
[ __ ] lithium instead of doing on
Nirvana bro smells like teen spirit yeah
it was good though dude he's a class
icon for ya so food I had a tour bus or
total ad and I think you brought me good
we're making $200 okay Nicole I'm Yuri
game we're bringing $200 for that gay
you know co-production and ever and uh
the headliner never made that much more
than 800 right I don't know what kind of
deal he pulled but bad hero for Last
Vegas show a writer and everything but
also Poland man was like right haha shut
up you see Mick Jagger dude the food
even is of Tina Turner the tutors uncle
whoa that one dude shut up so he killed
it destroyed was destroyed so give her
an hour outside hanging out with him
today he killed her dinner's gonna say
like it said about him not doing well
after us he made a groupies bro the
pastor better worse you know when you
try to outdo the headliner but you in
obedience groupie at the end so that's
the second time that happen to us what's
the first time for well let's get into
the to try to get to um about people
making flyers oh okay
so we're hanging out with his food and
this guy like a road manager whatever
your name is he want stuff to me and
goes yeah I may have a really funny man
you guys she makes
if you have any business cars or flyers
or posters or banners you know someone's
put get the word out there man I'll do
it for you guys alright man you have a
card or something nah like a guy trying
to laugh he had nothing nothing nothing
so the first time we're San Diego
Gabriel I was driving with her to La
Jolla Comedy Store oh then I was gonna
he was gonna like um feature of an open
this time and we're gonna work with
Frank Manzano Oh
yesterday I reclaimed the Alamo look him
up on YouTube we we can frighten
horizontality no Legend and life we used
to win with Paul's Regus oh yeah
he must have started like five years
after Paul Rodriguez because I'm look up
Frank Manzano comedian from San Diego I
googled that fool at him and I could
find for him with a flyer from 1988 god
damned doing a comedy aisle in San Diego
it was like a little side room that they
improbably to have to compete with other
companies in stage 2 section yeah but a
nice room bro really right I did that
one time with Willie it was a comedy
aisle it was then in the Mission Bay of
San Diego by the roller coaster a good
little district who they could give you
a nice little room and you open up your
room you can walk to the beach really
you open up your your door and you could
just walk to the sand you don't even you
just hit you don't even hit the sidewalk
bro you hump eat and progress it was a
it was part of the hotel and you just
walk to the beach there's people walking
around there and now your glasses it's
cool man yeah man sometime my father I
need to get out here man oh never you
guys know that she never were tell her
what happened oh my god were a little
vacation on my birthday two years ago we
were staying at the Sheraton somewhere
and in San Diego at Mission Bay also
right
that would've called in San Diego you
guys went there for like a weekend and
Philippe found this thing on Instagram
some brother like he's all happy face
Bahia resort San Diego that place has
also that Dale explains there there's a
lot of people that from our tech company
having a vacation they're a bunch of
nerds bro look the real Silicon Valley
uh-huh they're playing frisbee golf all
that finishes so we find founded I would
like to Google like Google search or am
at low hashtag Instagram to see what
other people thought about it so then I
started to up on this dumb
african-american man from Inglewood will
return or Carson and he's like smoking
you know he just stood smoking of blood
he was smoking a plume of smoke in a
blood and he's chillin the same spot I
was on the patio man looking at the
ocean you know for the Pacific Ocean for
San Diego and people walking around
families he said man San Diego man yo
some time [ __ ] need to get out
man
get out of the hood man is man it was
good huh now you're just happy to or
doing it wrong what'd he say just said
doing it man just sometimes and I'm
paraphrasing here sometimes they can
agree she like this or any be doing [ __ ]
out there yeah but doing it man
so that's the word by doing it you're
just not shining no more bad you're
doing it bro it's also to like doing it
means like you're at the spot where
you're feeling good you're having fun
it's not gonna ever get better than this
you're not sitting in a hot-ass
apartment on 134th Street oh man that's
the worst man when you're on the like to
live at the Denby he tries to come over
about a hundred degrees [ __ ] you
have to be outside on the couch whoo-hoo
thing you wanna get high all shirts into
an attitude called ghetto how ghetto it
got in that little bit
but it was a little studio I lived in
man it was there was Marshalls going on
a bathrobe and bucket mode it was a loo
joke oh hey yeah man
you can't even have a loo on that plane
are you have a loo so good times good
times man I don't know you totally
forgot that somehow someway somebody
gave me a couch and I put it in the back
yeah you had it for a while there's
algae now looking at the start to get
another building yeah there was a lot of
cool as little storage then he had a
little jungle back there when that for
wouldn't cut the grass it was a big job
wife we gonna cut I gotta cut it also
doctor third a to me succeed me Silva
remember that one time he started
cutting it but with one of those what
are those those grim reaper [ __ ]
things with little yeah I was I don't
hear a cycle it has I [ __ ] a fool of
pervert huh uh I was checking haha it's
not like a big regular [ __ ] but always
check out the chicks walking in there
hell yeah brother hold up a brief LOC
how about was that I was trying to
charge me Ivan and Vinnie dogs to go to
a bar in the back you put out his hand
like this and he would put his elbow on
the gate I like Philippe already pays
rent but [ __ ] this guy we had a column
so don't pay attention to that fool dogs
I was like I don't know that food loaded
up ah
do you always drink it that cheap ass
what was it cheap ass beer bro he's like
not even slit some nasty-ass [ __ ]
The Fool working bro for JBC really fool
a real would thought I would see the
daughter a book in a the red line in
sheet I think Norman and we should bring
it up [ __ ] about her dad and she liked
to go okay oh yeah she was I was kidding
no her friend brought all your
colleagues now and [ __ ] yeah but another
text she was on a date for the date huh
I'm gonna do is busy she heard it hurt I
can't believe they will rent a room to a
[ __ ] like me having a daughter
and junior High's your high school right
next to my room and greed greed I know
working great and it was a nun stanchion
back room but
good night and the books I [ __ ] call
the building department on these
[ __ ] dog so whenever I had
second tour someone up I know the dollar
400 and anyway when I was a crackhead
talking to myself I was crazy she was
all embarrassed huh oh my god or has a
bigger her dad's grill that's why I'm
big ass we had like a size 15 shoe I
thought he was a [ __ ] fight 11
brother with that tall but he was like
weird dick colorful he's in fat he was
just like big bone type [ __ ] yeah
there's little wise wise doctor real
palpable for women but the house down
look at the Chronicles of the literary
take me out bro I burned a house down
fool
cuz they wanted to rent money once a
month full the room was covered our time
bro
everyone I raised a rant on you fool no
problem bro
where am I gonna go I'll pay 295 bro
yeah [ __ ] it 295 just for real cool Oh
spot we're [ __ ] it all up have a
little garden a little kitchen yeah dude
but it's like if you're renting a [ __ ]
you know my [ __ ] is gonna make noise why
are you banging on the [ __ ] door just
cuz I got a [ __ ] full room that lady
would come up to the fence and then come
up to your door got stupid oh but
whatever done no problem I paid 300
because it clearly 295 275 in a big ass
I would like what I'm looking for a
place to live live I was like [ __ ] yeah
this place [ __ ] she was wrong with it
so I go ahead mushrooms in the restroom
that was wrong that was my fault brother
okay waiting two floors i wiping it no
butter over the Bible that's upstairs on
living with somebody by yourself you
really live how dirty you are remember
Doritos then I finish the bag and loans
your trash can I just throw the floor
dogs how do they I thought you're gonna
use that as a little trash bag I
remember doing a little mouse bro yeah
rock colorful yeah my little buddy but I
wanna kill him if he has you cocked our
food yeah but rumor I would put the
poison down that's all like he
disappears he died somewhere but you're
the door underneath you
because remember to be cold that that
little uh I don't say that gust will
come under the door go to sleep in that
area you sleep in your room cold
that's right man just up in the kitchen
yeah whatever we like everybody to how
the bro yeah we have my eggs
her son you Billy and Ivan bro
Philippine - and fill up in one little
spot yeah [ __ ] baby be stirring me an
angel
I was dude I came to the house two days
after I guess you angel liberal were
sitting there and that fool came up with
a sauteing that little uh rolling I
remember I got three new stall we talked
about it who this was said taught a dog
yeah cuz I've ever heard about that
Silent Bob you know everything about
weed we were hit will you be J bro I've
been my brother angel with his at
Roseboro that she was crispy with a
brother still good I put saute that
Roach and everybody had stories about
something [ __ ] up they did not like I
don't even have a [ __ ] story I'm
gonna say no my brother he got shot I
know we could tell you about a story
what brokers they are Bible tell about
what that man was guys able to go get
beer in Shea and never came back
who don't know [ __ ] is no humble but
that was real well that's what I was
really the one he said that he started
making a fake dope with almonds and
setting it to people then he came
blasting and they shot some fool around
fool supposed to shoot him that was real
man they shot Chivo broke the shoulder
man the [ __ ] another shoulders on [ __ ]
I should what hurt dog he left with a
big-ass hands bro so they say he [ __ ]
slap the bullet out but I bought a woman
Patel [ __ ] come on not desi
so whatever remember for what we were
popular Blasi Elena um we didn't the
roach it was getting small and then my
brother or somebody said then it bean
sauce and a gayborhood all [ __ ] up a
stone and ecology said watch somebody
say pizza for order seven pizzas see
hard times we seen real good we're doing
real good man it was just by okay
Green Bravo we order seven pizza from
hard times plan for the whole fam who
every time we would eat would be like
[ __ ] a like somebody doing like an
execution of the last meal ha phone I
think every now hold me go like this
awful in the middle killing I'm fatter
bro I don't know I think we're bill T
like that fool didn't we took dude how
many [ __ ] things the cheese when were
like like um queso fundido abroad six or
seven - [ __ ] bro and then they have
Sebastian right there [ __ ] putting
the towels on the chips trying to get
the grease off he's a hairy ass hands
bro I was a tourist move they're all
drunk and she don't still looking at and
he brought it up for mags crazy man
we're gonna go solji but yeah anybody
this will usually brother Bobby inside
Sebastian mansion ever not - got old -
gotta this out I just got a comedian
Pico Rivera Sebastian cuz Pico Rivera
Sebastian the counter Pico Rivera house
was really Dracula one away man he's a
king of Acapulco restaurants so this
fool we're doing a show Eric Blake and
somewhere Bakersfield I'm saying we're
not doing it I wasn't there for what I
heard it's incredible sort and see a
credible source saying that there was
commotion in the audience right if you
fool around side hanging now you know by
the merch table and I think that that
was killing it that was killing it so
the winning said go check it out they're
choking that [ __ ]
suppose I stays choking them yeah
there's Larry he opposed to get out
yeah they take they take comedy news
Mike Tyson's punch-out over here what
Covina dog I heard he was a former kind
of blurs every spirit of this guy I know
a full [ __ ] food be thrown Chingado
these days huh call the cops call a
lawyer called something but I guess
homeboy was making fun of the dude's
daughter dude saying she's out there you
know blowing fools and [ __ ] [ __ ] since I
hate whatever you know he's signing
autographs after the show you know
taking selfies homeboy comes up and
crack some they're out of nowhere dude
blindsided that fool it runs crept left
gone through that's the old-school punch
and run oh yeah he's done it before just
don't get caught player that's all I
gotta say so what'd he do I don't know
[ __ ] got dusted himself off pick
another selfie don't Oh what about this
but you other face I don't know he's
somewhere making a wrought iron fencing
[ __ ] that was a okay like it ah dude
that's another fool that got punched
another comedian but he always had a
good thing about it and then he's aw
yeah that he took those punches like
soldier died you got a light huh hell
yeah so man we're working with fright
McDonald man that's a la jolla Comedy
Store and this guy's like the king of
one-liners he's real dead pad by the way
super different super deadpan and he has
long here I'm turning into that guy he
has long hair and a beard and all his
jobs were like oh you know he's very
funny man he's been a power jiggin era
you see monkey locals - you guys like
the locals - - and um he's to live with
another comedian with a name Eddie burns
or something that a couple other fools
somebody brought him up about a year ago
he mention him some yeah me I saw him at
the fire station
Oh a diesel so so main camera like we
know him we don't even know him but you
know we're young common with you wanna
kill it so what do you wanna kill it huh
so the audience is like nope I swear to
god dude it doesn't it was like at least
10 people that was it yet you can't you
can't have a show left at a comedy store
in La Jolla with under 7 people so if
seven people paid you're gonna have a
show come out of work so so we had 10 15
the first night right it will be there
all week
first night all right I'll [ __ ] I
went through 20 minutes of material at 3
minutes
damn that crazy how I should happen dude
it was oh no bro
we're no energy for the audience and no
feedback [ __ ] I'm doing
energy up there no just words with no
audience huh yeah the sentence is dull
no jokes I mean [ __ ] they are before
[ __ ] on I'm so glad that I would have to
come come back like a bro just do noises
bro so man I'm up there bro doing my
bids and from partner in my peripheral I
can see the waitress wiping her table
done and sitting down to see if I'm
gonna be funny
oh damn I'm not funny god I get like
five jokes in that are funny but 20
minutes when three men I was done man to
him so I brought our game bro think it
into the rocket
he doesn't mediocre bro really just
whatever wrong this whole time whatever
you did better than me took it up enough
but I said I did their bad that bad I
did good enough to hang around with him
because he took it Barbie can be heroes
a killer like if I would like the guy
with a gun a standing ovation the
headliner
I wouldn't be too embarrassed to hang
out with him because you know I wouldn't
be like the guy who bombed and I get who
killed this tuna Haro
I was the gap of bomb this was close
enough to beYOU hang out with gay Brazil
because in a good example is a standing
ovation for hotel people but it would've
went back to the condo there's a house
the holster car-free [ __ ] is the house
so fried my daughter goes up there at
ease drank a beer or he had a diet coke
whatever first joke off the bat destroys
bro
it just had two people laughing together
like it's like they were unity like
before thought the rock sitting in
different chairs first joke out of his
mouth ah ah
he said the joke about I just reclaimed
the Alamo that gift shot will never be
the same
didn't I was a joke and then go on to
another one liner by that time you know
they got used to a little character to
people more two people came in okay but
I'll time he was up to no 13 people 15
you know so man yeah he ain't that good
but man he's the one that told him what
we were eating with him we're eating a
Chinese restaurant
and the bill came me and Gabriel put in
exactly of what we order and that fool
looked at it we'll get into the tip [ __ ]
daddy come on man you gotta break the
stereotype they say we don't care we
don't bro well every time somebody made
me tip broad I've been tipping ever
since likes a lot of cheap [ __ ] we don't
know yeah [ __ ] I don't know kind of
toy I can so I can look at that at the
time we're noticing that that note that
somebody actually brought us our food
we're observing you serving me I never
noticed before you know just thought
that okay you grab you go sit out that's
the way I used to eat broke grab it or
set out I used to take today my mom and
dad never took us to a decent restaurant
where you had to like aprons in she you
know it's different my like if you're in
a restaurant like that like sizzler with
your parents another place we don't tip
sizzler
we don't we got chip there my dad
wouldn't [ __ ] me up a sizzler like kill
me you know like town or scream at me no
they know he's paranoid you know but but
he'll [ __ ] me up at a burrito stand you
know but now that says look - oh yeah
live in a burrito stand and a McDonald's
you know he'll smackers but at our
sizzler i'ma take a look
he's our property a Stockton [ __ ] of
shrimp the shrimp you can eat shrimp bro
okay I'm not [ __ ] shrimp if it's
all-you-can-eat clm on my mushroom yes
we'll see must marry me sherry bro but
there's to hide food bro
I put diabetic now no need to hide food
dogs see what happened to me I'm up I'm
not gonna I'm like slippery but I hear
this I know it can be be an open subway
there's chip some liberal thank God yeah
my dad was like who live cookie
somewhere hidden my brother angel told
my brother to know where it was brother
Li I put the [ __ ] I don't eat it bro
for real nah he'll really like hiding a
little the little calories of dummies
ah there's a little caramel ones yeah
man old school didn't share there's some
people to lock up the fridge you know
that right for the kids okay mondo clean
off all its employees - no it's cool
chilly Devon why I don't know stepdad
had a [ __ ] lock on it let's step down
well the guy that was [ __ ] his mom
that's when they were getting killed for
over a juice he got shot by one arm foo
dog or goes on the news okay Paul Wong
PO rested piece got shot by one our bad
day yeah I do this week to break it up
ads and everything we warn our the guy
that shot him with had one arm it was a
cousin of his baby mama Woolsey how look
at all [ __ ] they have a plastic fake or
we just I think got a dead like a dead
arm and [ __ ] like you know like you know
will you stop on and [ __ ] it's just like
a [ __ ] pink and inches or whatever I
think using that move the fugitive there
well they got him from they got things
to make you have a better arm huh well
now it's like a whole thing
what digits everything I've seen it on a
it's the same company that made that
[ __ ] machine fool it's called Harlan
robotics and so they went up when you
start looking at our like that people
with prosthetic legs that are better and
more normal you look a while but they
cut my leg I'll get one of those kinda
you can afford that [ __ ] dog give you a
[ __ ] stuff bro [ __ ] Bionic arms
and that's a [ __ ] basket and bladder
so [ __ ] rich white people people with
it with [ __ ] power people with money
interests have people with lots of money
man did they give you a letter stop bro
gotta get a Kickstarter program in 15
bro is gonna be [ __ ] running marathons
and then kill his wife try to get away
with it like metal legs bro yeah the
[ __ ] dude from South Africa detention
15 you got locked up within metal legs
oh no to give a wheelchair what South
Africa to though and only they'd only
better later oh they give me though they
gave me the
the game is a handicap room and they say
Lewis just on accident one yeah okay
those noticed if the bay was all low as
I'd like to get off your wheelchair just
like yeah and then I said then the IBEW
ones are the eye view on the door with a
bottom row like what see y'all roll up
on your chair
yeah man the eye view for like people
knocking was on the bottom like if
somebody was knocking I gotta pretend
give somebody a [ __ ] I look to the
mirror
it's the peephole bro who when I was
different the shower bro it were huge
bro
I could start a [ __ ] racquetball club
in April I could steam that it was huge
Burstein value a huge [ __ ] have those
towels were lower [ __ ] I had to [ __ ]
get in I think I do um sit down really
low but the TV was low had to aim down
below Ratan yeah man hey I did what all
the dates are we mix it up were some
food okay man so fragments down oh he
killed it are we
I thought about that and um there was
one night man we're talking I'm about to
go to sleep right Gabriel already in his
room and [ __ ] and everyone over there
talking to him and he came back talk to
me and I'm laying in my bed in my
blanket arrival this fool like holding
the door he's between you know the Doria
to close he's telling in the door thing
or jam and the doorway he's telling a
doorway leaning broken hand like that
talking bro forever I'm like alright
yeah man and yeah what do you do man and
we're gonna walk around town see what
happen to me a beer or something what
time was like 11:30 bro 12:00 1:00 he
didn't want it to end he didn't want to
am remember in my blanket bowhead for
somehow gay bro a Mickey Mouse the whole
house with duct tape and [ __ ] tools
and he got cable and all the rooms bro
hell yeah dog the Cable Guy [ __ ] yeah
dude he fall like extra cable parts you
know the little
how you do it kind of coaxial cable and
yeah he found all the extra parts
somewhere and you hook emailed the guy
hurt him because because I'm one of the
TB only had cable in the beds of that in
the living room so we one in the living
room so gamer to that wire around I said
[ __ ] your brother he came in the room
watching right here yeah bring the TV I
think he [ __ ] he did all night we'll
put it together [ __ ] like a meth head
dog ha ha [ __ ] meth head and he wanna
watch TV you know watch TV hell yeah
buddy pull the wires together like this
was the Radio Shack or something
[ __ ] he was part of a team bug
[ __ ] sweaty dog he [ __ ] put it
together we had cable in the living room
and his room oh yeah dude we did it done
that's what Tuffle and I was in that
room was badass
- bro in a wise man when I keep it going
takes oh we're talking too much bro
telomere days May 5th in Colusa
California at the Colusa casino Felipe
Esparza Larry bubbles Braun Murr and
myself hosting so that's maybe fists at
acoustic up one in Colusa casino get
tickets at Colusa casino calm also
Irvine improv May 25th through 28 Irvine
improv Rodrigo Torres Toby Hicks will be
there you better not drink it's a long
drive home
Omaha's fine Omaha's finest anybody over
ha know who Toby hates it please hit us
up on a fan page want to know anybody
listening from Omaha Nebraska if you
heard of Toby Higgs please contact us
human
so that's May 25th through the 28th and
Irvine improv also May 18th through the
21st in Tempe Arizona at the Tempe
improv and also June 1st to the force in
Arlington Texas at the Arlington improv
and one more date July 1st in Tucson
Arizona at the AVA amphitheater with
Paul Rodriguez ma la tierra
and war at war in any further
information go to WWE world calm that'll
be awesome show may have been a two
cents and you and I were there God
yeah man Windsor huh fool [ __ ] Tucson
Arizona bro
Miele we're gonna be like we're not even
doing full sets
he said do 20 I gotta do 20 and then the
bands go work you should come out bro
I'll be dead before I bring the podcast
together but everybody does hell yeah
[ __ ] especially that food although I
would probably get poorer legends if
you'll be in your casino so there's
gonna be a badass show propel our cholas
there [ __ ] tux on veteran atropos our
bro love armors a lot of El Paso buddies
Oh God
do you want to hear that song slippin
into darkness that's my favorite scene
of American me man when I go take out
that little drug out of her butt mobile
she's like god yeah that one may
releasable oh my goodness to taste drugs
on her but yeah yellow vagina and then
the prisoners ticket of the Batman when
i DM the boat movie i look up everybody
and I really looked up that lady she
should be like like a stripper from Las
Vegas oh oh the actress the actress I
just feel like she was like one of those
lady lady to do one one of those dances
in the 70s and 80s the showgirls
showgirls
but a Barbara's very popular one so yeah
my little history about American me my
part about that woman is taking out the
heroin and then look at her digging it
up to that pole yeah what that pipe they
open it up all that [ __ ] that's I guess
that's one of the reasons why they got
mad you send silver bullets to people
and [ __ ] first of all right it just like
hit now it was crazy very do anything
you want look for a YouTube is crazy but
don't they talk to all the cholos from
Hazzard
I lay on it and you see all the ones
they to say that they didn't happen that
way yeah man I think that she like 10
years ago it's a good one yeah a lot of
foods talk about that they were in it
today's episode is sponsored by Dollar
Shave Club
our second week having - a club with a
sponsor thank you very much
- Dollar Shave Club show your support
for our podcast by supporting our
sponsors Rodrigo has been using the
package they stand brought ton of the
game bro
like a baby for real I'm not even
messing with it
no this is not the thing the only thing
is I did mess up because I used a razor
more than once so I think you're only
supposed to use it once and throw it
away I use it like four times so I think
it's good for three even though they say
one new prison bro no just like I look
at the direction they look good to me so
I scraped myself up on that catch yeah
but I'm the little raised for the first
time right yeah yeah the first two
please Ramona I will talk came all
smooth I shaved yesterday so I got a
little bit of stubble but it was uh the
what I like a shea butter I see a
two-minute different tool um would you
did that snapshot with [ __ ] uh Katie
how also I change that morale yeah I was
smooth no it does work my mother like
because I have five of those Rangers one
thing I'm not gonna lie to you it's a
little bit bulky but the cut is smooth
all right so it's straight smooth do you
recommend it though I would recommend it
and recommend it and if you don't use it
I mean it doesn't matter you have to get
the shea butter the other thing that's
cool is it comes straight to your door
shea butter that's like a lotion just
for your face for a solution
no it's for before the shape it's
different than all shaving cream you get
the hair buds out yeah well not to use
them do they use like a couple herbs and
stuff it's it's it's a trip what they
use it's Indra I don't remember it had
that little package but um it's it's an
alternative to shaving cream there it is
activity and another satisfied customer
there you go back so um what's up Fred
what are you [ __ ] with I'm straight
razor now I just do an electric I always
cut myself I was never taught her to do
anything
some I'm a schmuck actually once in a
while I let it go and I treat myself and
they do it for me at this Italian place
model it's not politically to say you
know the R word but I'm that with a lot
of things I can't change our word razor
[ __ ] all right Rosie go okay well
hello all right maybe you're not going
to be in sponsor for that if you're
suffering from fretting for an older man
if you're shaving with Forex or just
plucking it out make the smart choice by
switching to Dollar Shave Club and get a
great shave at a great price deliver
right to your door and
who's dr. Carver's shape our judo uses
the math debate that's a problem our
liberties time only
I should've body burn out for a limited
time only new members get their first
month of the executive razor with a tube
of their dr. Carver shea butter for only
five dollars with free shipping after
that month the raisins are just a few
bucks a month your first part will
arrive and you'll get an awesome heavy
handle razor a focused set of four
cartridges and a tube of the shave
butter no hidden fees no commitments
cancel anytime you want all right you
tell you matter you know what I just do
it because you love it to it but you
don't like it or you can't afford it
anymore
cancel it man or just senator somebody
as a present somebody who needs a shave
somebody who look like their favorite
cut I'll cut up and shame em or mad my
face to be cut up man forget this deal
joined today a dollarshaveclub.com slash
food that dollarshaveclub.com slash fool
you're looking good bro I don't is the
girlfriend making you look good or sis
bulldog like the guy say would you go is
shiny knee
there's a full tummy now she's dressing
you hey bruh I got the bug dog there the
jello may we have a guest a very special
guest with a new thing to sell share to
share with an advertiser promote
advertise hear the new Kindle single oh
yeah I seen it was a fool are you doing
broke away from westward the mayor of
the Grove in Westwood relocation program
the mayor of the Grove ladies and
gentlemen the man who mentions people on
Facebook and then the people he's
talking about right away know who they
are and he get mad
yes yes she's got the same problem clear
like that woman he was talking about by
the woman that let's go was going onto
the next shuttle to her name what the
[ __ ] bread when you're [ __ ] talking
about me I get I get in trouble a lot
yes is there some people that hit you up
that they're not the person that you're
talking about ah yeah the coke bucket is
how
yeah the guys I know you know they take
the guy from my other book who I didn't
use his name in the book and he bang on
the door I got a restraining order and
then he goes did you mention me in Marc
Maron like I know so why would they be
mad if you mentioned them on Marc Maron
wouldn't that be like advertisement for
that fool so we got people we mentioned
here on the [ __ ] pocket they get
pissed off oh yeah that's all you're
telling them oh my god you're a hack on
Facebook anyway bull shoutout to that
guy man he looks bad but [ __ ] fish oh
yeah
so hook up my book that guy I was at
dude I was gonna book him on the show
you didn't return my calls or Nothing
dog because both divas I might is what
is wrong with people for whatever I
guess it's not show business some people
write and show better maybe I should
walk back to fresh daughter but our
guests who win a gold when you just get
away you know and we're all cat at home
from well under catch by the way oh
she's great she's great
but uh she stopped biting got it down
are you going on here give her a razor
already every army you know you were
talking early about not knowing about
tipping right and and you have have
things in your life where he was so
clueless you you you feel embarrassed
about yeah the birds about that I when I
I'm so again you can't people don't like
the r-word but I am I did this I
headlined in Cleveland of like 1988 I
bombed I I'm not a good headliner and
they had some guy the club hired to
drive you around you know a limo guy
yeah the runner he was uh I don't know
if it was his own limo company or that
they just had a car and he would take me
to the club because you know you stayed
some qualified and and I didn't know
you're supposed to tip in my I wanna
wish I could track him down from thirty
years ago and give him some money
I'm an idiot I ever do something you go
die it's not that I was cheap I just
didn't host something as simple as that
I did that Olive Guardian in Glendale a
brand the bill came out to like whatever
the bill came out to I were there with
my brother my son and my old little
brother he was smaller at the time and
we just finished eating and the girl was
really nice to what she really took care
of us
when it came down to the bill where they
have enough for a tab man we snuffed out
of there like savages but you at least
you knew you were supposed to she's
bought like seven orders of bread yeah
and you didn't but you knew he was
supposed to at least you could go with
enough money and I said I took probably
myself that I was gonna go back and look
for her give her the money I never did
see some accounts wherever you're at if
anybody knows that waitress hit a cell
in center tempo only what a long time
ago I was in I think st. Augustine doing
so the [ __ ] is out and I know that's
lard I think about all the old a pity
Miami Beach Freddie oh no it's the North
st. Augustine or telehealth of Florida
so this is like 1999 so at the TGIF's
I you know they did the waitress
recognize me from dumb and dumber and
made a big fuss and and two before
cellphones took a picture for her
brother and I tipped well I think
probably respectively 20 percent I went
back to the hotel oh so neurotic
thinking is it because you know did she
acted like you know Michael Jackson
Michael Jordan came and you know the
biggest person ever to come in that
TGIF's so I really was so neurotic
thinking this big celebrity in her mind
came in and didn't tip that much so I
went back with a rental car 20 minutes
knocked on the doors closed ago oh his
extra and gave $5 extra Wow it cost you
five dollars we'll go back yeah a rug I
don't know I but again I was so I've had
that a few times where someone
recognizes me and I feel an extra does
need to tip a little bit more because
they don't want to go that [ __ ]
I don't know and I'm not really you know
no one's registered with any of this no
no you were a bigger restaurant and
recognized doing the guilt they take you
the food for free I haven't had that
about seven mean they say you know
you're you're the guy for real model um
don't your are your money's not good
here
now there was a guy feel bad who used to
he worked in their farmers market the
ice cream place and he was a big fan of
scrubs and he goes you don't have to pay
and I'd and I'd always get free ice
cream and and a place closed and he's
out of a job but maybe because he gave
the ice cream away but my nobody hot and
even I want to take advantage keep
getting free ice cream and I would you
know tip him extra and he would try to
say no to that but yeah so uh I haven't
got too many great perks I got the ever
get laid sneakers none every sneakers
what happened is I was open for Norma
Donald right it'll fit me hey go ahead
put it on you big dummy
that's Ave does impression he so this
guy on the plane I work for Nike and and
when I'd work with norm
I'd have to [ __ ] do everything like
he doesn't that add uber he does anyone
hate he knows he humped them for the
show hey and I'd have to pay for all the
uber rides he never wore pants that had
wallets that was his excuse he's like
where's wet pants yeah like what aaron
has are their wallets in that sir
suicide okay but usually I want roll out
so I'd have to pay for everything else
hit them you know I don't have the
wallet so that's my Norman [ __ ] so I'd
always have to compair a game comping
Freddie so and I did remember what show
with such a headache like murky when you
open you over to him you don't have to
do all these errands you don't look
these assistant oh you don't have to
like well boy you're certain [ __ ]
doesn't matter though I mean but not
like all [ __ ] demands have a leash on
me or now I know what's here when I went
back with over it's the worst because
you only pay you back for the ubers not
really more Wow
no he gets compensated for it it's the
over if you because sometimes when I go
lift so they work through that is uber
one time I got matter to give me your
phone I'm tired of paying for the uber
so I took this knife and a Lube wrap it
wasn't connected to the credit card I
went alright you got me again but
there was this guy that recognized him
and I Compton for the shower he says oh
I'm the Nike guy get Nike sneakers for
everyone
so I took the information and and he got
some free so [ __ ] NICUs and long what
the [ __ ] guys the big guy from Nike I
thought it to be a truck coming up with
sweatpants and and racks and Josh and
wag yeah all this I just one [ __ ]
pair of sneakers so he goes you got
better ones in me what the [ __ ] I'm
doing from norm junior and then and then
this is what I do so cut to enjoy the
free sneakers I had to go to the Nike
store and see how much they cost how
much of these pretending on the by him
hunt in 60 so that I started feeling
really good because I had to see what I
got for free see how much it was to
really appreciate it you know they were
like 60 bucks have been like [ __ ] yeah
this guy but 100 Scola wins again you
guys no pilot in the world didn't say
too much about norm but if someone had
it like the dabs are no dad haha but it
ever did - out but it got air annoyed
where he was screaming at me you know
from the side estate have you done the
Denver comedy work
yeah the beautiful Club no problems I
was despised but nobody walk you're not
downtown so you know the morning-time
family it's just like a restaurant
there's nothing but a movie theater and
a restaurant and all that one will touch
you're the one that's the other one
right we did our the worst the city of a
sober there's nothing like this so it's
like being in Orange County without the
character and there's nothing to do
there so so we decided a grocery store
again I'm taking the uber he's yummy
where the [ __ ] is this guy going did you
know I don't wear anything is so he
forgot his pants for this gig so he's
yelling [ __ ] we gonna do I don't
have my pants you fix this so so I go I
thought there was a mall because a
restaurant and and they said this is it
the other time you say he also forgot
his pants so so I suggest company
sweatpants
and of this buzz buzz web pen but not at
Tom Kenny that's he doesn't waste Bob
norm
he's like like Al what's-his-name
Sharpton you know it just goes up in
that no no they run germy now we can all
Sharpton only wear sweatpants
okay back suit yeah yeah yeah yeah so uh
so is just nuts nuts working with norm
that's good you put your pants
what what are you wearing he wears
sweatpants on the plane
and he wouldn't have jeans or anything
he never packs in that you would forget
to pack real pants summers getting
really high I say yelled at fix this so
you don't yell at him if you forget to
back things you don't yell at Rodrigo
that's not what openers are supposed to
do comp everybody and keep track and do
burr and so so then yes oh you need a
white guy's killer hybrid are you guys
old buddies what buddies but at the
opening I'd have to do everything you
what about almost time you do collateral
those 15 2020 well it's a thing he he'd
get all like he'd get all like he'd have
this thing where he thinks he only wants
to do 15 or 20 to headline it isn't
thank you thanks he only want to do that
so he yells at me to do long and didn't
anyway anyone hanging out at the club a
you go up there wants to only do short
if he only wants to so so then I asked
vertical 20 yes
yes I said got a fine waiters only I
texted Keith to to please maybe he'd
like my Kindle single about the young
comedians special he saw me on but that
guy with Asperger's I rightly saw his
mad at me because norm would make me
kick him out of the green room and a
norm would Norman make up Freddy doesn't
want you here
he would tell he was Sexton threat you
can't open Freddy doesn't want you here
good this guy is mad at me good one
though don't know what I get on my back
and you Angelo she was Oh like it will
tell you that that will be
calls Angeles Iruka good why you crying
Mauna Lani Lucas yeah so this guy but
Asperger's would call Keith up crying
that Friday doesn't like him but it was
norm that made it up so she can walk him
around so I can't intelligence Maggie
honey well lots of things I got first I
started to do 45 this is what happened
the first the first time I opened for
him I hadn't done spend the last time I
did stand-up was you and Tempe with the
dabs and I was I was out of shape you
know there you know that out of shape
yeah so so they pursue your great then
he texts me well no this is like five
months later oh I hadn't did my set in
five months he takes a hey man I got a
Vegas tomorrow and you know at that
point have you done South Point South
Pointe where it's like a casino having
it so so so that way yeah whatever right
you know I could just do 15 you know
just put flop it together yeah together
so then I'm on the plane wouldn't you
know I don't I counted and he's texting
get the [ __ ] over here why y'all right
man here I'm on the plane he goes are
you better I'm tired I don't feel like
doing my Jose you got to do the bulk
tonight like a wino ball yeah he goes I
only feel I'm tired I'm not out of shape
T I go norm I haven't done my acting
five had to go what the [ __ ] I go I I go
I don't need to be deceptive but you
know I thought you know just open goes I
need you to do the whole DIY only feel
like doing 20 and I'm freaking out on
the plane buggin open up reunion you're
not gonna know your people but what
jokes to write I'm freaking out right
now to jokes and I go norm even in my
prime I your prime Freddy
when my phone was believed in yourself
when my prime was headlining and not
tipping limo guys in Cleveland I didn't
do an alley that's right a 45 that's it
goes a 45 year wall just took 45 I'm
going my wall I apply even 45 I go what
I go I
the idea of opening for someone this is
no stress but well stretch you go there
huh so he's going eco you gotta [ __ ]
do this you know you know I bet are the
middle guys and you know they don't do
it right so some freak I got kids I got
girls I said I have a gig with him in
Atlanta I'm gonna cancel that you know
he'll and I said worst dictionary I'm
going to write all my right jokes on a
piece of paper and pretend there's
birthdays and you wouldn't talk very
sentiment Oh
so I'm [ __ ] awesome though dude I I
took the club angel the club let me read
all these birthday so I'm thinking so I
react in fiber so then I so then so then
he text me I go norm
I really can't goes he goes look I
remember your act you come to my room
and I hope you remember your jokes I'm
going why are you putting energy into
helping me remember my act when he
should just do so then I'm going to wear
my pension and so then I'm freaked it
out and but I'm thinking something's off
because why would he help me come up
with my long said put that energy into
yours so so I'm backstage too afraid
worst-case scenario you could he put
comedy again Oh sucks you know I'll just
bomb so then the own in the younger the
manager were backstage he goes okay
Normie I need you to do at least an hour
oh and I'm gone you know and I'm
thinking that go yeah good yeah just
bread only do 15 I'm gonna norm that the
guy said the guy wait a minute he's
taunting me he's just [ __ ] with me
because they don't pay 50 bucks to see
Norma Donaldson and have many to an hour
high pressures on his act in five months
so he got you yeah well he's a
ballbuster yeah he's a big bully and he
likes [ __ ] with you yes
Seraph already but he's big off to the
place right [ __ ] first I will go
assault were to relax
[Laughter]
oh no he would still do that like when
we were at Irvine like Adam eager came
with al Madrigal and that was really
funny because the guy would Asperger's
kept pronounce it you know you know cuz
they know so no because yeah you go up
their album tin wah no there's [ __ ]
she wants he wants that show to go long
that way he wants to do 15 he can but he
always does an hour and a half norm so
so then um so so keith is a practicing
automatically a metrical I'm not you and
he's pacing to get his lunch or those
who put us right up so then he goes you
next act is Almirola Beck what's up [ __ ]
hahaha beating that guy however he was
so like [ __ ] I really have never
given up a Keith hotdog perky sorta yeah
angel freak like anyway you know look
iin wide-eyed enjoyed working with you
but all those improv sir like they all
look the same
Lindsay's um but the same way it's just
like some depressing mall and your
photos yes and you wait back there the
worst is Irvine because they say they
don't even come by to see if you want
food and I'll say I'm not doing stem
[ __ ] the Irvine was the worst they were
really not nice to us and so then I said
can we get his ice cream and it took
like 40 minutes they forget I thought
they were the way goes out no I was
makin into special ice cream they just
they're bringing it in for Brooklyn they
did for the prince
so that's in my story well you know it
sucks working with this is not normal
but but this happened to you to see when
you work on the road do you have this
well we had the guy with that I think I
look like a Mexican Dahmer era no you
had two guys in one guy who foo
there was a Mexican Dahmer era that was
a father and he just goes in the green
room other Tempe with us right yes and
then it was another go yo Seinfeld that
crazy guy but I am stand up if you're a
local guy they had they think they could
just sit in the green room and press
their girlfriends and
and their wives like I'm hanging out
with normally they clean out every now
and then you know so so I norm never was
able to say you know what these guys
there so I have to do it so it's kind of
weird you're sitting in a room with five
great local good luck holes do you get
that and the all one time you don't want
to be an [ __ ] go hey we want but you
can't hang your charge it all on your
spot they want to be you huh you could
tell that you're going to want to get
really close to to the headliner and
start talking about this joke but you
know they're like like analogy if you've
played some music you know you can when
Aerosmith performance Madison Square
Garden you can't just hang out back
there because you're a musician
I bet analogy I can't think of a good
one I know what you mean though right
yeah yeah you got a [ __ ] cuttlebug
Google overstay their welcome dude you
know it was an example with voodoo oh my
god cuz I especially like like boot like
the Voodoo glow started to blue glow to
the gentle opening theme song for the
water pool podcast and they're on tour
right now so look for him this is a band
that grew up from Riverside and has a
lot of [ __ ] friends and they are
typically go hang out when they're at
home oh yeah then people like so you
know you got 30 beers inside of an ice
chest you know it's your backstage and
all of a sudden there's seven beers you
mean people dip it in the deli tray with
their fingers and [ __ ] and that happened
a [ __ ] bad days it's not ordering
food - it's all a reasonable dude yeah I
look like I understand whether whether
openers being that I could order well
then you said you're not on the show but
they're locals and they bring their
wives and it's on there and why are you
sitting back there rest of wipes of
girlfriends they're hanging with nor
McDonald Oh presents are on [ __ ] far
away and or they just well you know
basically when we were in Atlanta the
clubs aren't there anymore
so the Bruce Bruce and we'll hear what
everybody would be people hang in there
and this is normal McDonald you know as
much as I say you know he's annoying
he's a big guy he was a farce I know
where were you wet it was an improv I'll
develop that look at the other improv
troupe they were I lived at Atlanta once
in that place is closed for some real
estate problem and was in cotton
Buckhead oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
in Atlanta and go the punch got a
punchline we did the puzzler - yeah yeah
Buckhead yeah and it was not gonna yet
but you'd have these local guys norms
onstage and some of the local gonna
dance that that looks like me but blonde
here with a beard I didn't see him there
but they're talking in the green room
with their girlfriends Norm's whole set
like I don't want to hear comics you
have respect watch norms act or in the
thing but gabbing other people are Gabby
they think the backstage is like the
traditional backstage that everybody's
back there doing cocaine no jobs all
that [ __ ] and it's not like that people
are working a sequence yet Irvine improv
getting back on like we know that's not
to bring a little kids it happens like I
know it when that was the more time
hanging out my my niece's they come up
to me because we want to come to your
show they were little bro like 12:30
eleven years old but they knew a body
writing it because yeah girl wants to
show no we wanna be backstage backstage
when you me back to get back Dean's you
know where everybody that brother magic
happen there's food unless they just
this thing there's a little part even
they know there's a look a little
gathering of people brought little
exclusive you know we might do theaters
or those little casinos at norm I would
take carrots and he would serious go
there's a [ __ ] mind you get your own
rider so I couldn't even eat all the
fruit but if I would touch stuff with a
[ __ ] Ellen you know no he's kind of he
thinks people taking advantage of you if
he's [ __ ] with me it wasn't funny
we've been building this for a long time
because I want to take a carrot or some
fruit and Betty he said we need that's
my [ __ ] stuff you got a writer well
I'll tell you a quick story about like a
tour bus driver back in the day window
blue I'm telling these stories because I
know normal and listen to them no but
check this is and this is this clears a
lot of [ __ ] out right and I see two in
another tour manager they kicked ass
that I seen on like goddamn
but anyways blue got a tour bus plush
tour bus back in 1996 bad ass Prevot
[ __ ] top of the line so like a lot of
people were hanging out trying to get
into um trying to give the tour bus and
hang out after the show
but a tour bus drivers I mean this
[ __ ] pulled out pictures he we
sorry crew while
who [ __ ] Ozzy [ __ ] Aerosmith you know
chicks pregnant he had a [ __ ] album
of Polaroids kind of like [ __ ] one
Dexter but nevertheless he come to party
down quick he's all straight up there
people chicks hanging out with the girl
result if you ain't [ __ ] the band if
you ain't sucking band get the [ __ ] off
the bus that's what I seen some people
who believe in people would stay get the
[ __ ] out of here
Goering [ __ ] house up here ain't
sucking us what I would say in a tempie
but anyway stay that lateral so back to
the [ __ ] deli trailer I don't
understand that people hang out bro like
I remember like I don't want to say man
cutter I give this fool shot up but he
sucks he got beat up at a club one time
hit by the club north the club like he
made some people pissed off and he got
beat up by not even if they come hang
out at our shows wouldn't he my name is
gonna show like a local community wrong
what I'm saying 981 that show these were
all local yeah and he ordered food order
a beer and it was a metal of my gonna
pay for that so what do you mean you
know but you're not even gonna show you
not even invited what you're doing
that's you better pay for that and that
flew I know you didn't pay for you
walked away blood no came back yeah dude
it's [ __ ] I've seen like [ __ ]
people trying to get all you right now
went to the show in our okay yeah
I haven't plugged my kin daughter we
like it we're we're going over here this
is a credit oh you just wrote a new book
hell yeah he can't happen already hey
guy our but it's good it's funny I
didn't think went by
yeah there you go yellow Kindle what's
any woman got fable about em over here
it's a Kindle single it's it's like a
dollar ninety nights like my Seinfeld
yeah these are mini box and I'm looking
cuz I get this full dog okay because the
author title no idiot
it's called very startling a grown-up
kid for newsy get the paper the paper /
the paper five minutes to kill but the
subtitle
how'd all five ready to kill yes that's
not a bad five minutes to write a 45
minutes dead this is what local comics
should be read instead of [ __ ] trying
to [ __ ] smell farts
yes five minutes to kill how the HBO
young comedians special changed the
lives of 19
funniest comics that's the long subtitle
so what I'm trying to say here and these
are many thoughts no but if you if you
guys read things on Kendall this is on
Amazon and my Seinfeld year did really
well that was a Kindle single Tori is
writing on Seinfeld so basically if you
guys are comedy fans now you guys they
remember this but the young people don't
remember that before Hulu and what says
so everything is easel so I don't know
what is what customer the world I've
messed with I'm saying record why did
Chicago drop the bombs on your movie for
all of these um
you know Alex before Comedy Central
yeah in the 80s and the 90s they weren't
all these outlets to make it but if you
got on them you could break it was only
HBO and now Johnny cars out how those
the only people affected for half hours
oh yeah if that was the first one ever
seen was deliriums if you had half hours
the nod that kumari Oh Joyner was
hosting that that came like 18 a dinner
so but in this the late 1780s and 1790s
HBO did his annual young comedians
special Boston right Boston was in
Boston excited about the world only
danger that was a danger feel T like the
water people hosted like delirious yeah
host Robin William hosted one and Jake
Johansson Joe Harrison hosted well they
were really big like Sam Kinison dice
Seinfeld Saget Robert Towson he had a
different one he had one with Townsend
and so your inner you're one of them no
no so what I'm trying to blow up with
these young comedian specials were how
big they were you know I mean do you
remember these so huge yeah so they were
spades
yeah no no so there's the one I was on
so I was on one in 1989 hosted by Dennis
Miller and I always found it interesting
I like all Shelby's stories you know
they're going I thought I work as a
question about that one shark
well Dennis Miller really really mad
that the last comedian had the same
delivery as him now he rameshan it off
days though the guy that had the same
time here well he okay except for me
Dennis
picked his favorite comics okay we
thought again all right good it was sort
of no heat what happened was I'm David
usually only do thought five comics and
this is called five minutes to kill
because you've got to make your mark and
usually we do longer but Dennis Miller
did a really long set and David Spade
had been turned down twice for it and
they were really fighting and Dennis
wanted him so they added a sixth spot so
basically I was listening to Marc Maron
and Rob Schneider was on and Marc Maron
said whoo what was your break he goes
the 1989 young comedians special I went
what the [ __ ] I was on that why was it
in my big break what did I I sucked out
too many liberties creativity actually
Rodney noted Rodney hold a special
Rodney hosted these young and so I
auditioned for Rodney's specials which
were really big so I did pretty good I
said writing what do you think he goes
you're too low-key all right buddy woman
to sir you too low ha ha ha
ya know so splits you know you know so
I'm took the liberty yeah so so that
somebody did that to you from ISM for
know he doesn't want me totally Jewish
cuz no basically so it's just a story
about the six of us on it
what happened you know following our
lives and careers after this big break I
don't want to give away what happens but
not everyone made it like Rob Schneider
and David Spade from it
others have interesting stories who you
never heard of so I just I interviewed I
bumped into you I was into the other
side and though the book you were doing
a book then yeah yeah so I had to this
was kind of interesting because I had to
bother people to sit and talk to them
who knew the people David or ease what
the people who made it the people who
ran the special you know because what
happened to them they had very some
tragic stories some funny some I had to
do a lot of research and find out so one
of them Bob Rubin was good friends with
uh
Warren Thomas so I was he was a great
guy we talked for two
hours and I got a lot of great quotes
and stories I learned a lot about the
San Francisco comedy scene I didn't know
the 80s they were like rock stars
a lot of those San Francisco guys never
came to LA because they did they freaked
out they you know that the biggest deal
in the world and the bay and they burn
more there were more of the comedies ooh
there were more gigs and comedians in
San Francisco in the comedy boom so yeah
so I was totally Ruben so so I had to
bother a lot of Club a lot of club
owners I interviewed there was one guy
now you know my god did repeat you know
my Seinfeld episode based on the real
thing where this guy gave me an Armani
suit wanted a meal for it and and so we
go out and he goes I'm just gonna have
soup I'm going to save the meal so one
guy I took him we went to Nobu what's it
called in Malibu and I interviewed him
because I'll take it easy I'll just get
appetizers it came to $70 and then then
we went to Waffle and he goes I got more
information so he kept getting meals so
then he can throw the talent he kept
holding back his information going I got
another thing to talk about so then he
texted someone who texted Rob Schneider
and I got a I got I had hung out with
Rob Schneider a place we did I thought
it would not bring so much discipline
well he will need so then he goes now I
want a real meal at Nobu not just
appetizers because I set you up so it's
kind of crazy adventure I'm among them
selling us at all to the people live but
tell straight ahead how you got wrote
this book a lot of meals I think Dan I
had 3 3 people they wouldn't put a
recipe three of them paid for for me
which were nice so school day day day
but I had fun I eat alone I would talk
to people if I feel like a detective
like how many community were all this
special with you just six six and you
got stories on all six of them to see
how what happened yes amazingly that we
did book yeah I think you'd like
it's uh and I know commonly about
comedians I think you'd like it it's old
and it's I'm not a tech guy and I know
norm would be uh oh yeah when I'd be on
the road you know he goes you're the
tech guy
cut my Wi-Fi on like he didn't know when
we get a hotel how to put this thing on
so do you have to put connectors I'm
just kidding no that's crazy man we all
that other stuff I would think that
everybody knew god damn now he didn't
have to do anything there's one comic
Dahmer era right he's worked he doesn't
know how to do a what's a cold uber and
he pays a car service for 80 bucks and I
go darling we got to Oh Boober he goes I
don't know how so he's not cheap he just
doesn't know how to do over Wow
not a good somebody beckandbill dirty
Camille you know I think oh yeah no this
book has a lot of stories a lot of
people who [ __ ] me over some I didn't
mention name some I did some give us one
example one guy when I was getting ready
for my what's it called my passion night
before the young comedians special there
was a courtesy in the comedy clubs that
if someone has a set before there was a
million shows they could Freddie work on
his Tonight Show spot is yet young
comedians special could he go up and do
it remember that at the class and this
guy goes [ __ ] no he goes [ __ ] yeah
Freddy Stoll he's a young comedian
that's a joke is really young he's an
up-and-coming guy what a dick go there
for ten years okay well I was okay but
yeah Richard Lewis was on the young
comedians special he's probably 45 when
he did it yeah right like 80 now huh so
then the guy goes on stage and he can he
complete he continues to mock me I'm
this young guy right so I have some
stories so what happened we beat his ass
away they're good to go up I went up
after he went up and saw that [ __ ] and
and and emptied the room talking about
what a loser I
who is this guy he did a book rule and
yeah I gotta buy the Kindle and and then
so then I go on stage and I think I did
a right and then I saw the comedian I'll
tell you he was wit norm from Canada
they just came from Canada and he's
going oh those jokes you couldn't do I
don't like it you're gonna bomb and
little messin with me but not but just
really going you have because your
weakest jokes and it was freaking me out
and I didn't norm what should I do yeah
so this if you want these kind of
stories
that's the Kindle single do you or your
fans comedy a duality fans so do you
think they'd like this get the budget
book at the show yeah yeah yeah yeah I I
met I really got hernia from care in the
Bucs
I remember man thank you a nice you a
nice but sometimes when you put merch
and you're not the headline oh my god
it's like a flea market
yep [ __ ] blocking my spot and I got
elbowed he's the first one that ever
said it to be honest and it's truth I
thought I was um at flappers and and
bubbly and I put some of my books down
and this guy elbowed me like Katherine
Carly but it's a famous day was but but
yeah Darren Cod will put things anywhere
hill-hill hill-hill wait out here you
know if he did a podcast and think to
sell Aaron you know he did a guest but
but shirts know he would do he was doing
eight minutes at the Hermosa and wait
with his things and be dance and when
people come out right develop but yeah I
perform come on leap a I'm surprised you
let me uh do that being the middle
because a lot of these people yeah it's
like flea market competition what the
[ __ ] you buying his book you know I'm
the headliner
did you remember you a buddy got mad how
when they set up if you sign the book
too well I get I don't care man outside
anything man no I got to give no I'm
credit because he he did sell merch but
he would sign my book and then they buy
it because when the hernia because norm
signed it see how my book on American
game you know we have you write these
damn books yeah
yeah hardcover I think I got I got the
hernia after San Diego cuz you're on the
train and and I try to [ __ ] carry the
Train well you know how you have to be
able to out you know that you know those
things that are above your head you know
the you have you taken that back to San
Diego is fun it's fun it's nice and you
took the Surf Life right yeah and then
you pass by supplementing you could see
the water I remember and go this is
beautiful longer shut the [ __ ] up
already but it's beautiful
your [ __ ] we never saw water for [ __ ]
it's beautiful here because this [ __ ]
beer magic Televisa shut the [ __ ] up
already your boy over here notice [ __ ]
never saw water stop [ __ ] to run the
water right next you man
yeah campus he doesn't experiment are
never so water every stop is nice huh it
was it was it was not you always were it
was fun because then we get out of San
Diego and you see all these these guys
about to douchebag college guys those
sailors walking around a fellow
retailers we return a classic movie like
coming to the new town and the tail is
just got out from the war and you know
they may look it you know she uh now you
know everything I'm saying it was fun to
open working with norm except you know
to get yelled at parts you know bored it
was my car yeah who's this pearl yeah
was a full fresh daughter and how well
yeah you're Kendall it's on Amazon and
you don't need people go do you need a
knock no you just need the Kindle app on
your phone your computer and your I your
iPad and it's a dollar ninety-nine it's
it's less money than a lot but how long
is the book like eighty four pages do
that's a [ __ ] book it'll have some
real pause that's a funny joke it's a
dollar ninety degree and you know so I
want to read it for the forward touching
I'm bad at selling myself and I think
you'll like it
are you gonna do it audible yeah yeah I
think I am was right well it's going to
be weird because I I this David Spade
didn't hang like it stole her over here
yeah might have to do impression I mean
yeah when I have to act out but I did
the audible for my Seinfeld year about
writing on Seinfeld I had to do Larry
David who knew you'd ha ha ha why don't
you uh you Joey's not like you you had
to do Larry David yelling at me so I so
if I do like Rob's going on is to the
Dennis Miller next stop is that guy yeah
[Music]
now so uh I remember that show man I
remember David Spade had a funny joke
about watching YouTube yeah at a concert
and we got man I was sitting over here
and at the Luther seat way over here and
they were yelling our stuff I don't know
what the hell are ya Lee what what what
the yelling no war he said no more no
more no more
and then our brush that I had to talk
about dude to to make if they do it over
and over
ya know there was that Schneider some
other drinks a day oh man Roxanne was
very funny
I'm live bull Rammstein I did a thing
about the glove back such a clocks back
doing phone sex and call waiting comes
in you know my hands on your butt beep I
gotta take this
yeah so why let's see they they have a
cover and everything five minutes to
kill see the little logo oh yeah it was
a logo yeah and five minutes to kill how
the HBO young comedians special change
the lives of 1989 funniest comedian
Kendall single I like it
comedy history at its finest go up can
you go up with that are my myself a year
after first dollar return with a memoir
about life and death in the 1980s and
the 1990s HBO's a new young comedian
special was the ultimate launching pad
for emerging comics
looking to break into the world of show
business the young comedian starts to
produce some of the most recognized
the book and bankable comedic stars of
all time including Sam Kinison Bob Saget
Jerry Seinfeld Apatow
but what about the ones who don't
exactly make it in five minutes to kill
actor comedian Fred Stoller the kindle
bestselling author of 2012 my sample
here tells the story of young comedians
special 1999 he and five other talented
then-unknown comics took the stage with
the hopes that the five minutes set
would propel them to the fame and
fortune some like David Spade and
rubbish later Haiti big others getting
to hanging out with my with Norma Donald
by turns heart when she hears a big nor
MacDonald to sad
why would be amazing book man mystery a
[ __ ] movie you should do the audio
the way you read that wow man you're
done maybe you can hear [ __ ] your
[ __ ] book tall the one map maybe they
help you back - it's hilarious I think
oh man it was I couldn't stop reading it
when you made up the left with those
basketball players to ask about I'll do
my imaginary back oh my god that was
hilarious
oh man man it's usually get that job at
jack-in-the-box of Burger King my
medicals yeah they're waiting for you I
say that I'll really to say that all the
time man you had a funny idea yeah the
waiting for you there waiting for you
man even at a pearl house slippers doing
all she's also mad she's happy I got in
here a new cat yeah she's really great
but you have a cat - right
no I don't have a guy a stuffed cat long
time ago all right like I love that bug
they love animals huh
yeah damn burgers I wish I could be like
you and be a vegan I just don't have
discipline you like baseball frail you
don't care how I lost interest like no
basketball watching the playoffs you
know I I lost it just but I watch the
finals yeah at least I love the finals
in the playoffs Jess she never has time
to watch Oh who's like I shouldn't have
ever said that I watch a game or TV in a
while so are they only a first round of
the playoffs in the other little first
round no I'm saying that in the NBA is
the first round
we don't even know were so full pocket
dimension besides your Kindle uh next
week make sure we have cookie hole at
the Romano's Andres at 7:30 p.m.
check out the yam and podcasts have a
new one with the porcelain doll and
shout out to pearl who do you have this
week on your show
Alfred Robles Johnny rocket over the
show so it's fantastic
okay great as always classy show
business everybody pays five bucks five
bucks if you get broth man and teasing
man when you pay five bucks you're gonna
be like we gonna buy a beer also man cuz
five bucks five bucks you can have a
good time with $40 by yourself
Oh Hayley I do man all these free shows
man hell no man nobody buys drinks kills
the value in that [ __ ] dawg
you do a lot of free show friend you
know do that [ __ ] huh what people get in
free
I'll have you out to one day just man
and now you waiting mean like bring a
night yeah you go do those up now he
said man who the poor unpleasant people
Oh simple turn up at Chili's on man
someone just texted me and it was routed
45 minutes to kill tough [ __ ] they want
you know you to look at whirlwind over
here oh they're not right alright the TV
let my opponent on some sort of people
listening who [ __ ] what's up food are
maybe I want to watch a good movie on
Netflix Egyptian and watching a
documentary about about our Mexican
wrestlers it's all based on three
Mexican wrestlers Santos and this little
little person restaurant name on mask
Aleta dadada
it's a little person and another guy I
forgot his name right now but him and
his son wrestle it's deep broad I didn't
know that it's all taken out of opera
really the place the way they are
exactly so there's a heel and a baby
face in America but in Mexico is rude Oh
eat technical and Wow
and I never noticed but I'm Mexican
wrestling and regular wrestling is the
the only sport we
could express pain because I pushed
within your ego ah coffee a miracle he's
nothing bro baseball you get hit by a
ball nothing but nobody showed pain
really by wrestling so popular yeah do
you just [ __ ] enormous I don't know
it's [ __ ] on like that though but
what's it called it's called um Lucha
Libre element on Matt I don't know the
name of it but it's on never left leg
bro so can you check that is no good or
bad attribute is good man okay so now
we're long what you watching on HBO I'm
watching I'm watching right now watching
beep and I'm watching Silicon Valley a
silicon unity I got night of I saw the
night of my friend Jimmy is on Silicon
Valley you know Jimmy uh has he been
here Jimmy yang a little Asian guy yeah
yeah he's polio - oh yeah yeah yeah he
smoked a cigarette
Danijela break there was a one really
funny thing where they were pitching and
he was from it there go what would you
say if I told you it's like pitching
from a roof down there um III got I like
the leftovers have you seen the left at
all haven't seen them have you seen it
it's pretty good but items might info I
didn't fall in love with that reese
witherspoon one I tried one episode
everyone's talked about big little lies
and stuff have you like that Erin I was
better call Saul Jiraiya shaking the
head you thought the same way not loving
it yeah my wife loved it but I I thought
it was lame they're just slow yeah it's
just again I sure are my people he said
now so let's go love it not a big little
eyes all big little eyes now it's a bit
everyone's talking about that one do you
do did you try two left over as Erin no
I haven't III ain't sure I love
leftovers of this morning which one
I haven't sure I've been said yeah it's
a good show man with the call
insecure with this array it's good man
I've mixed feelings about better call
Sal about that show good I don't like
the law stuff like I'm an idiot I just
want the breaking bad guys I know it's
not Breaking Bad
it's older going back side there's
another one they're coming back like the
characters yeah that's the only part I
like I saw that
just and Fran was talking to two guys
with um yes you know it's funny man
about TV now like when I was a little
kid and I watch a TV I just waited
watching Bionic Woman or I finish
watching um I'll um Dukes of Hazzard and
then show you a preview for next week
there's actually show you stuff that's
gonna be any next [ __ ] week now you
want you finish watching a better car
song or one of those those newer shows
they show you a walking dead they show
you a preview and that [ __ ] preview
it's not even a preview for next week
it's a [ __ ] preview for two seasons
from now I don't know they don't show
you they just give you a taste what's
going to happen in eight more episode
for now but they don't tell you they
don't give you a previous gonna happen
next week that's what bothered me okay
that's my rent okay and yelp review yeah
man
fresh burglar in the house you wanna
watch them on TV you gotta watch Dumb
and Dumber how you double your gonna put
see if we put a picture of us suffer
ready official bro okay
first no no you have any shows coming up
with nor McDonald no all right now yeah
II yeah yeah I like I'll tell you I
think ISM thank you simply next day so
what he talking about house for
everybody who listened tonight today's
episode of Iran no I'm not a Dollar
Shave Club yeah Dollar Shave Club yes
what's up fool damnit on portal 2 and
check out our amazon portal on the
flippers world.com with each thank you
very much for solar [ __ ] always grand
Oh [ __ ] knuckles over here he's gotta
meet you Mir yang the two toughest guys
we talked to Davis fight and weekends
are fistfight